lo que se conoce hasta el momento Es que
la reunión será en horas de la tarde en
Caracas el próximo lunes 21 de noviembre
y que fue públicamente convocada la
prensa nacional e internacional a dar
cobertura lo que sería formalmente el
reinicio de los diálogos de paz entre la
guerrilla del Ln y el gobierno
colombiano la información fue difundida
por la oficina del alto comisionado para
la paz Danilo rueda como parte de este
proceso la fiscalía colombiana anunció
que se levantaron las órdenes de captura
contra 17 miembros de la guerrilla del
Ln una información que fue remitida a
Interpol en esta oportunidad se
incorporan al equipo negociador del
gobierno colombiano el actual presidente
de la federación colombiana de ganaderos
una decisión que sorprendió Pues se
trata de una persona bastante crítica a
la administración de Gustavo Petro
también se incorporaría OTI Patiño un
antiguo militante del grupo guerrillero
m-19 Grupo al que recordemos también
perteneció el actual presidente de
Colombia Venezuela Cuba y Nicaragua los
países garantes de este proceso que
recordemos inició en 2017 bajo la
administración del presidente Juan
Manuel Santos y que fue suspendida de un
año después por el presidente Iván Duque
luego un atentado terrorista cometido
por el Ln en Bogotá